[Music]
hello everyone it's happened we're here
we're here we're here good we're gonna
play Deadly Premonition can't believe it
on the Nintendo switch of all of the
things that happened we saw how to get a
new version of Deadly Premonition
announced yesterday during the Nintendo
Direct in a sequel prequel thing yes
like so we have deadly premonition too
and then they told us deadly premonition
origins movie like available yesterday
and I was listening and we both looked
at each other and freaked out it was
great because you could immediately
single out through all the fans of
Deadly Premonition we're in the audience
or in the in the office because all of
us just kind of like stood up and looked
at each other
excuse me this is happening like it was
a great direct but this was one of the
highlights for us because we are clearly
big Deadly Premonition fans I also love
Twin Peaks so I just have love for all
that's happening right now but I'm with
Ben I'm Cassidy and we have John Luke
joining us right now around
are you okay is everything okay
everything is fine nothing to worry
about it's all going according to plan
are you guys ready it's for some
investigation for some mystery for a
murder and very exciting and if any of
you guys are here and this is your first
time seeing deli varnish and you're
you're in oh boy you're in for a trip so
we don't know if this is just the
original version as it was or if they've
made improvements it's not the
director's cut it's kind of a fusion
yeah it's got like some of the visual
upgrades of the directors guy I've
noticed but it doesn't have like the new
intro and
dr. cutscenes it's Morgan he's on the
case like the framerate seems better oh
yeah original definitely in this room
already you can kind of remember it
being kind of this that's original
rumors count ruff yes and there's also
got the the different UI yes like the
cards are different different yeah we've
got the trading cards so let's give them
some context but why don't you tell
people about deadly power what kind of
game this is so if you know twin peaks'
I'm gonna say it's just totally cuts out
that number of people have seen Twin
Peaks you guys are all caught up and you
know what's going on I've never seen
twin behaviour if you don't know what
Twin Peaks is you don't know what deadly
premonition is you play as an FBI agent
sent to like this town in the middle of
nowhere to help solve it it's also in
Washington yes you get sent out to try
and help solve this murder
lower lower just I'm a little worried
about spill just just like a touch I got
you the kids are there it is kind of
going off a little bit yeah the murder
of Anna gram which factor an anagram and
through your adventure it turns out
there's a lot more going on in this town
than just people getting murdered
there's a bit of supernatural a bit of
crazy a bit of yes I see this is not
normal yeah and it the game didn't have
a very high budget when it was
originally made you can probably tell by
looking
but the best thing about it is if you
can put up with how looks touch on that
TV writing and characters are entirely
worth any of the like rough spots you
have to deal with yes it's about the
journey it really is now we have heard
weird issues with the sound cuts out yes
alright just like the sound effects just
will slowly start to disappear like York
won't talk as a car engine Alcoa has
Kurt described Kurt the other Deadly
Premonition super fan about this
describing he couldn't be here
unfortunately he literally got up and
was like dumbfounded and almost cried
it's with excitement I'm kind of sad
that he couldn't make it
he's busy doing if you can real work
we're solving a murder Anna must be
avenged there's a killer on the loose
find him but the audio bug this might be
the best version maybe you'll find out
we'll find out I'm not very curious
we're also hang out in the chat so I'm
over on YouTube if you guys want to ask
any questions about this talk about Twin
Peaks with us talk about Deadly
Premonition let us know if you played
this game I'd be curious to know how
many of you
now this whole scene
it's the perfect intro degrading crap so
what this game is yes the heart cut to
the music the the music cuts the
conversation that he's having on the
phone I'll spoil it it's about Tom and
Jerry
because York loves like popular culture
things he does he loves 80s music he's
just constantly talking about pop
culture all he's driving around he talks
about like courting Star Wars on VHS so
bad this is so so good but the cherry on
top is the sound of the squirrel makes I
don't remember the sound of the squirrel
it's not a Ryan so what's different in
this version we don't know you have a
hundred percent sure yeah so far just
the graphics are better than the
original but it's not the director I
tried to look it up and there were very
little details outside of like people
who like to plate it like they haven't
put out anything we've got a lodger own
investigation figure out warpath back
finding it out in real time this worth
playing from the beginning this cutscene
looks pre-rendered yeah like a little
little choppy on this TV this is looks
like a 4k TV
[Laughter]
wotcher said I've played this game on
the ps3 that's great first played it -
yeah it's been a while yes on the ps3 to
get version so the interesting thing is
he just talked about the Scarlett on his
face and that's my only hint that the
new game that they announced is gonna be
a prequel because he doesn't have it
well there's other reasons but there are
there's some very specific reasons I'm
kind of hoping like that has to be that
has to be a prequel oh yeah oh no it's
that raincoat killer right I went for
the scroll Moyes
[Music]
let's go mix but it's this whole it's
the perfect way to show what you're in
for
weird I hope you ready I'm so ready oh
yeah
mode man said I started playing the dick
just kind of ps3 love it Twin Peaks but
need to go back to it yep and now you
can play it on switch if you want did
any of you guys tried the motion
controls they had on the ps3 version I
did like joy Khan support when we tried
it because this was actually one of the
first preview events I ever went to war
the directors quite a deadly premonition
that's awesome which is when I first met
swery and now we like go and get drinks
during it's a good time and that's the
only time I played it the only time when
they were like you should try it
civilized world and you instantly fell
in love with this game but knowing that
I didn't
kurz in the chat he said I'm so upset I
couldn't be on this stream I don't say
you couldn't be on this video I hope
that we do you just this oh yeah his
flashlight back his flash light that
shines through his coat yeah so you know
it's working man see how this house is
more zoomed out camera of the ps3
version yeah yeah frame rates better
than the PM rate is much better the
frame rate on the ps3 version was worse
than the Xbox version we've gotta try to
pay attention to when the sound starts
to count offensive mode man mug man 101
says the squirrel sounded like a
chimpanzee
you nailed it that's exactly the sound
that we heard that's just how wacky this
world
okay guy remember like okay give us the
bumpers to shoot is that a thing here
I'm spending yourself it that's deaf
this is definitely the you wife yes yeah
there's a hundred percent very nicely
done
thank you Joey sit so he's dead now
right no he's not dead no no this is
weird stuff is happening but I mean
that's like theory but that's not
because I was looking workable it's a
workable theory there is definitely like
this weird stuff keeps happening he
thinking like okay he's dead this whole
thing's just in his head right or he's
in a coma and this is all a mystery
which is also another line of thinking
for twin peak series I kind of hope you
at least make it to the coffee scene
late I hope so too
yeah I just want to drive around and
have him talk about also work does the
thing that I wish more videogame
protagonists did and that's like psych
himself up every time he gets a good
shot on a bad guy oh yeah you think
that's a good job yeah it's really
wholesome but you have to be your own
biggest fan right it's true if you don't
love yourself who's gonna love you
I love York I love you York so here are
some clues York's optimism is like very
inspiring it's like I'm out you're my
idol I want to be like New York looks
like we're being welcomed Zak I'll let
you handle the meet-and-greet
you got it Zach's on the case all right
here we go
just gonna gather our three clues to
figure out what's going on and yeah then
you got to do the profiling after that
there's actually some pretty cool kind
of like detective stuff going on yeah
yeah
Jesse's you been show you the I guess
I'm the Japanese direct they showed more
footage permission to he has a
skateboard it just starts going oh my
goodness and sweary the director of the
first game confirmed that he is
directing and writing happy to hear that
cuz I cuz he he has his own studio now
called white owls and I noticed their
name wasn't on it so I was like alright
let's see what else is going on in the
chat
yeah I'm actually really impressed so
far how smooth this is running yeah I
can't believe them into us which version
is the best running version even against
the PC version of the director's cut the
like the the revision of the game that
is on a PC doesn't run as well yeah the
pickles is this pickles so I love how
there is every every item in this game
has like a area in the game where it
just infinitely spawns so there's like
one area I think here where you can just
like infinitely grab like pickles
pickles but I think like every item has
that like has this one weird like hey if
you want like infinite crackers go over
there to see input in cracker area the
other interesting thing about this game
is you've got it kind of like you've got
to eat food and you yeah you have to
clean yourself and change your sewer in
my knife or shaving looks really good I
didn't shave my entire first place I
just let it go oh I like bearded your
clock though I like I feel like you got
you maybe go Beauty York like when the
when the plot gets real down in the
middle it's like yeah alright so this is
the
right let's check out some of these
combat how's it feel okay Sharan the
aiming is actually pretty okay you have
to like lock with the right trigger and
then hit with the right bumper so that's
kind of a little awkward a little bit
one of our other options all right
[Music]
oh yeah and they start to hate how they
so gross turn the whole verse take it to
turn at bandage ten whole dollar is you
did it
but yeah you do get different suits and
stuff which is cool the rain the rainy
suit is a favorite cuz it's just like
like blue and darker blue pinstripe yes
that's a good one
I like the hearts heart suit seems
really good different suits sometimes
they'll give you different benefits for
wearing them which is always a good
thing I think I think the one that I
wore the most actually didn't even give
me a benefit I just liked it cuz it had
like a like a red suit coat mm yeah mr.
by hell my bad mr. come my coffee it's
okay it's the first time I've been
attacked so directly so direct but your
scar on your face
never mind doing it there's no logic
here life is fun because of the
mysteries right Zack kind of here though
the audio doing it yeah like peeking a
little bit my it might still keep our
eyes up see what happens
lollipop crime is asking is driving
better here I got so many glitches and
struggles driving we'll find out yeah
we'll find out for you yeah I think this
is the infinite lollipop area right here
infinite lollipops good old time
I think Kurt was talking about the
driving a bit earlier too he said that
it felt heavier okay the car felt like
it was maybe going a bit slower than it
usually does
yes he's saying they're worried like
physics things with the car on the PC
version yeah I'm wondering if maybe like
the the speed or something is tied to
framerate and maybe that's what causes
it to do weird things possible jvt said
is this the director's cut it is not the
director's cut it's it's something in
between like it's got the graphic and
the UI of the director's cut and seems
like some of the controls and camera
improvements but it doesn't have the new
content like you didn't we didn't have
like that extra opening scene with him
it might have the the costumes and stuff
though because I saw there was a special
spot on the menu gameplay I feel like as
first I'm aware it seems like
everything's here except for those new
scenes which is kind of ok wait
I didn't mind those again I didn't mind
them but they kind of the kind of stuck
out is a weird thing to me but a little
bit yeah Sergio said buying this tonight
enjoy heck yeah it's it's a good time
anytime someone decides to jump into the
Prohibition mm-hmm it's funny me and
Kurt we're talking about it like
actually like two weeks ago about how
much we wanted it on switch oh my god
but just willed it into existence that
is insane also apparently a Jim sterling
who famously gave this game of ten on
destroyed he apparently tweeted
yesterday like before the stream like
Deadly Premonition on switch please but
we were talking about how me and Curt
both have never but really want to like
100% this game and then get all the
cards do all the quests that sounds like
that's a lot of money it's a lot it's a
big commitment and that's why that's why
we were talking about the switch version
you guys were like well that makes it
like the ideal way to do it what do that
it come on commutes like you can just
pull out my switch and quickly do a side
mission or to keep going it's possible
so this might be the version where I
finally that's why I was like hey man
switch though oh well I mean if you just
dock it at your desk while you're
working and you sweetie
Gabriel said streaming over watch when
it releases on the switch probably
happen I think I'm definitely going to
play overwatch again when it releases on
smooth
yeah
melee weapons so good they say there's
there's something weird about how the
male economist through the male egg it
looks and feels better I confer the
melee yeah I mean you know the gun is
fine but it's get right in there the
only thing you miss out by doing male as
you don't have York yeah I mean you know
you mix it up well it's really great as
we get the machine gun because it's like
it's very much thank you
it's very much a pea shooter yeah yeah
but every time you hit more clues he'll
just keep going like he just like says
it like there it is there's thinking
pose in high school me my friends I'll
play this and then we would just start
going like this so I I didn't ever do
that the one that I picked up I think
was his like whatever he like makes a
point and someone's like leaving he does
like a thing like that I do that yes
yeah we did the tap we did that and I
think we would just say like isn't that
right like all the time David said how
much is it it's 30 $30 per prising Lee I
have to like it's weird because anytime
you recommend this game for anyone you
gotta do like cabinets that's I'm easily
going to spend $30 on this today yeah I
I bought it before I messed around a
banjo last night without even like
thinking about how much it was also but
we're also fans for fans out there so
you can pick it up now digitally but I
think in like a month there's a physical
version that releases it's Europe only
but the switch has no is it's region
free so you can go pick it up and if you
want to have a nice physical copy for
your collection just grows bigger every
day I have I have all three copies
nice and one of them one of them's been
signed by sweary those that was kind of
the whole reason I went to that press
event uh back then for the to get my
xbox coffee song but I also got to see
the game yeah I got to do it just as a
fan of packs I think us feel about like
bringing thing I feel weird about the
idea of like I could bring this thing
and have them sign it what I'm like
going there for like a work thing I'm
like I don't want to be weird if that
feels unprofessional so I think it's
alright on the down low it depends on
your approach right I guess so yeah
it's silly about the approach I've been
waiting for Tim Schafer come back to the
office because I wanted to sign my
physical box I think at the very least I
would do it after like go in do your
busy job profession yeah and then when
it's done because sometimes you know
afterwards you're being very casual
yours Oh how's your you know event going
bub on your being and then you could go
hey by the way oh you want me to get
grass let me grab because get grabbed
really do when you get I just like have
a second remember that
[Laughter]
Oh smack yeah
my going we're hanging out in the chat
on youtube if you guys have any
questions or want to talk about Deadly
Premonition or twin beats already your
like anything from the direct I won't
talk about Andrew at some point so how
is banjo I'm playing it how is it
perfect
tell us about bands yeah like it might
seem like a thing you'd say outta I
probably be like it's everything I
wanted it more but it literally is every
song I wanted is included it there it
like most of them are rearranged that
they're like better to fight to which is
fantastic music all of them are great
great songs are great arrangements the
the level is fantastic it's got its own
gimmick and I love it and banjo the
characters has just got a lot of like
care and thought put into them the
reference all the games at banjo has
been he's fun to play I love the sounds
are all there he goes it's I love it and
I can't wait to play more looking
forward to playing about sands sands I
haven't made a me fighter with the sands
out yet but I did fight for that new
version of megalomania earlier
added no it's just that you get the
remix version Meganium what stage does
that plan on its on any of the like you
know the stages that have like a list of
like X fangs
because there just isn't like a set
stage for that one right
just like you play on wrecking crew with
the pilot okay so there's a lot of
staging that's good it's a very very
well done to the arrangement to man
smash is good harrybo guards on the way
that was quite the video to when they
had all these other characters that was
really yeah if the bird can't catch it
anyone get shoes I saw her pop up I was
like oh god it's gonna be a samurai
shodown character yes there's a really
good tweet were cuz in in that video
geese Howard he like jumps off yeah he
fell into Tekken do this it's got big ol
axe
a relator runs off into the woods
I remember my like first or second pax
there was someone who is cosplaying as
the raincoat killer and they had really
read like light-up eyes really good I
would I love that hmm it was a woman
doing it - oh really yes she was awesome
it's got great taste yeah yeah
the other cool thing too going back to
Terry is someone pointed out that it's
the first time that Terry and can have
been in a game together in a very long
very long time so last one was like cow
come vs. SNK they showed like the gif of
Ken picking up his hat and like handing
it to him I was like oh yeah they know
each other this is fantastic you got
redeye v- r 3 put all together solve the
card solve the crime profiling start the
weird thing is that this just shows like
the entire day yeah there's the entire
sweet sugary candy that really was the
entire game anyway thank you for oh we
should have got doughnuts for this show
Oh biscuits biscuits $5 crackers hi
Coffee warned me about I got coffee oh
you was very it was my coffee was inside
of a tired garbage there's enough room
in there for the entire statement mode
man 101 said did you guys watch Twin
Peaks the returned aka season three yes
I did I watched every second of it I
have yeah I actually haven't watched it
yet and I have well now you have the
benefit of not having to wait a week -
that was painful my family bought me the
blu-ray set but I'm like fine time it's
one of the most ambitious seasons of
television ever that I've ever seen like
it I just can't believe it's TV finally
watch it and I've basically an 18-hour
movie I've managed to avoid spoilers if
that's good if you're even capable of
spoiling it yeah and if you are we
watching it we've got breakdowns of
every single episode of games about
universe gamespot universe please check
also you guys say you're about to get
tired so tired
[Laughter]
yes vegans real tired
oh he's winded he's just had a whole
night of fighting you know he's trying
so hard
thanks off against the raincoat killer
trucker hat tried to show his hand down
his mouth I can't can't even deal with
it
so this is when Kurt said it started the
audio starts all right it sounds like
it's not it's definitely a bug because
it's apparently very inconsistent and he
said like we start gonna be fine
yeah Emily I'm deputy sheriff all these
characters are so good I didn't think
you'd keep me waiting in the rain for so
long sounds okay yeah yeah I'm up a
little bit Francis York I forgot you
introduces himself that way just call me
York that's whatever calls it good
that's good yes you've got it yes good I
see if you don't mind me asking did you
walk all the way here yes and whatever
it meant your car didn't break down
you can greened off into the forest yeah
whoever's to go find that
[Music]
[Laughter]
dude she's like right bear what are you
saying yourself you crazy man
yeah she'll definitely figure psycho she
doesn't she already doesn't yeah she's
like what is going on with this guy I'm
George it's George with that stache this
is what everyone calls me
[Laughter]
FBI Special Agent Frances York do it
again do it again
[Laughter]
I think the lighting is maybe not quite
as yeah George's face looks like it's a
little overexposed yeah
like the texture works definitely the
director's cut I think the lighting is
maybe a little pale little PEZ a little
pale yeah but I forgot that like the ps3
version was like more saturated colors
the original Xbox versions like very
desaturate gritty nope definitely gritty
just want to set things straight our
small town has its share of problems
I'm the one fixing us it's time to pull
out a cigarette it's got that like
Andrew Dice Clay like smoke technique
going on doesn't have a solid snake
ashtray - yeah he like puts it away like
he literally like he might do it at this
point but he literally like takes one
drag off of it and puts it away
yeah and comes back to a later someone
to take care of it is that like it's
like pocket actually Japanese things
like I've only the only time I've ever
seen one was in metal gear yeah it seems
that could be a useful thing like I
don't smoke so I don't know but being
able to just kind of take care of that
in that way seems like a very good
holster especially place like Japan
where smoking is more common but also
they're more conscious about like not
littering and there's like less trash
about it so if you smoke I feel like
you'd want to have like your own pocket
afterlife because you might not have a
place to put it away also it's just very
hard to find a garbage can it's weird
it's like they have they have less
garbage cans and cleaner streets somehow
but I don't know if we have like it
doesn't matter how many garbage came out
so he put in like San Francisco it'll
still be justice for all so it's it's
worth shouting out how great the
soundtrack is to this game it's very
good anytime there's something
intriguing happen
happening you just get this weird like
screeching horn music it'll just like
smash cut to a punk rock song will start
playing because someone had a
realization and there's no warning it's
just right into it and it's it's
beautiful also something I didn't know
when i first played through because i
never did it was if you go to the
junkyard and do all this quest to get
the different cars you get in cars for
different like that like belong to
different characters which is weird that
you just owned their car now but every
car has its own song so she
which is like really cool that is
awesome I love the little details here
$200 basic wage love it find your way
out of the woods so rich that shotgun
shotguns real good mode man said been
John Luke you need to get on season
three but watch fire walk with me first
ever guys things are awesome have yes so
that was part of it was that I was like
watching rewatching Twin Peaks because I
own the original blu-ray that has like
the first two phases and fire walk with
me feels like going through the mom and
then that's one like I got I was like
actually almost done listened to I was
like two episodes I'm done and then I
got distracted and never picked it back
up so I need a leg quickly finished that
rewatch friar walk with me and then go
right into it
[Music]
you might need to be out of here what
the the song for the pause screen is
basically just seal is it Kurt and I
were we're talking about that a while
I'm gonna look yeah you're right it
literally is never I never thought about
it that way like like kiss from a rose
almost straight up I love that well it's
a great song yeah I have this weird
thing where I keep hearing kiss from a
rose and keep thinking it's Nickelback
for some reason I don't know I keep
thinking like is that hero from the end
of spider-man what I do it George is
like how dare you but those are both
fine songs there I'm cinema history I
like both of the best best song from any
of the spider-man soundtracks indicated
- poor confession - I'm glad you don't
hear that song very often anymore us
thinking hope dangles on a string Ben
there's there's like a like a meme going
around for it or something like like
that outer Dashboard Confessional did it
for a meme and like they I don't know if
you can do it I don't know if that's
legal but they did it
also this I didn't use this mechanic
very often because I know when I get
freaked out I've done it I got to do it
hey you gotta hold it there is a hold
your breath thing cuz the the whole
thing is like if you hold your breath
the the enemies can't see that you're
there yeah but I ended up just killing
this lady does he get like money from
shooting diamonds yeah you'll get money
for holding your breath your money for
killing create that like it's a game
deboning it chicken or something like
yeah the sound effects sir
Oh gross there's a whole walkway here
man also the first time that this
happened I actually held my breath oh
really yeah
the first playthrough I ever did this
game I actually stream the whole thing
so I got to like the whole thing yeah I
got to learn about it with a whole bunch
of other people who would watching why I
did it
that sounds like a fun way to it really
was cuz like no one would come into the
chat to spoil it because no one had
played it yeah so we just all got to
figure out without worrying about it I
first experienced it through a Giant
Bomb
they did their endurance run yes please
yeah they played through the whole they
play through it twice and I liked it so
much that I watched this game so weird I
want to watch the other playthrough with
the different people so I can see their
reaction to that scene so weird audio
gore oh seven three three said what is
this this is Deadly Premonition origins
it just dropped on the switch yesterday
it's a version of the original game like
how different but yeah it's on switch
now the size of this never played it
absolutely the blanket it's a huge yeah
it's like look at that blanket I don't
think that he doesn't touch any of the
other ones easy not the first one I I'm
the kind of person you need Bob likes
linkages the portables I look at least
two pillows
I've got like yes seven or eight yes
exactly I need to be surrounded by
Phillips Zack the symbolism in my dreams
continues to intensify I love sleeping
in my entire work outfit twin angels he
just wants to be ready for work at any
moment yeah he's a professional knows
his job I've seen him before
just can't remember where
what does it mean we're starting to
little time to shave soon mechanic Isis
I still say bearded York is the best
York all right what do we got here to
the cafeteria SEC yeah let's go to the
cafeteria check check out one of my
favorites yes there's a bit of a
procedure for everything yeah you're
right that the cameras different I mean
the original game it was like tank
controls like Resident Evil 4 style is
definitely better what do we have any of
the extra suits in there there's the red
one that's that's the G most yeah let's
do this one for dry-cleaning
so change this clothes looks brand new
all right cool very nice looking good
feeling good
where's the uh nothing do they not
remember when I in the original when you
turn on it's like a dude skydiving or
something changed what was on the
television yeah I remember in the
original it's like this guy is like this
real up-close of him being like maybe it
changes maybe possibly whoa Oh framerate
down a little bit there that's cuz you
got that mirror in that mirror tech with
real-time reflections like how desperate
he is when he moves into like the the
bathroom he was kinda like pushes the
door open
yeah he pushes doors open with a lot
urgency crime said Zack is basically
Diane yes exactly that's pretty much
what they were going to Zack just the
way that a coupe talks to Diane and Twin
Peaks yeah so see they were like yeah
he's very delicate with the door or it's
just like BAM I don't have time this is
this is a top scene in the entire game
[Music]
the other top scene is the one in the
diner where they talk about the sinner
sandwich it's pretty good
you have $35 for some crack no I don't
apply anymore I'm fine
brain said why does it sound so bad
audio seems like super low hurts yeah
[Music]
audio issues I noticed it's been
inconsistent where some scenes have
sounded lower also yes this is the music
she's great
the song this is the Sun the song life
is beautiful if you ever want to look it
up the best forgotten it listen to like
trap remix is this one that I go to all
the time that someone made for Giant
Bomb actually I think I know the one
where they said great like young audio
clips and they're sound clips of him
knocking it's it's Ruby Tom I know the
exact one cuz I'm pretty sure I have it
on my knee be on point here so
ridiculous lovely has to have been on
perfect where the song is the same
volume as them talking and and they
can't hear each other so she's like what
do you say in the music's too loud
what are you saying any other guests or
workers here oh no one else my husband
and I used to run this place but it's no
I can't
[Music]
together it was such a large table from
all the way across the room that's a
reference and it hurts like crap yeah
I'm hearing some crackling
[Music]
you know really I feel honored the lady
is offering to tell me about the town
yeah say Polly what can you tell me
about this town the music just holds out
of cigarettes I'm ready for a story
we're gathered that it is called thank
you I'm amazed just listen to smoke
inside yeah
apparently here that is from the
original game that that terrible audio
piece it's it's perfect those not cheat
I chose not to fix it
agreed
many centers
it tells you the time
[Music]
times during your
it
yeah I love the idea of someone picking
this up being like yeah this boys uh
kind of got some problems and everyone's
like no that's that part's normal that's
how it should be this it's working
beautifully just right back to this is
the song yeah all the milk cartons got a
great theme tune I would do like guitar
the milk bar apparently is based off
like literally just a like a gas station
or something that's like take all this
and put it in there yeah I know they
went to Washington the spare sixty-five
sixty-five there was like a I think you
can look in the extras photos they took
like reference photos of like a small
town in Washington thank you I love the
idea of like a bunch of Japanese devs
going to Washington just take a bunch of
pictures a station put that in the game
this needs to be there it just sounds
really cute coffee bring it out very
particular about my coffee the very best
you have please
this is my language a damn fine there
it's oh you ready for the button prompt
oh yeah it's coming up got you got a
peer into the coffee
you got a teller fortune
with interest I see it clear is a crisp
spring morning did you see that Zack
Claire is a crisp spring morning F okay
in the coffee the coffee I knew I could
count on it it never fails
it is very unsettling
[Music]
[Laughter]
as if I'm all mechanic - you can just
come back here any time and drink your
coffee and get some get some advice
which I don't think actually ever helps
you I think it's just like random advice
like oh you should go to a theme park
today or something no not that one play
moonlight sonata that was a great scene
I love that cafeterias yeah but that
seems lovely
- it's very Twin Peaks observe yes we
want to get more coffee more coffee
all let's get to that driving yeah yeah
all right Paulie
catch you later that times really
quickly yeah great thank you
I left the little Zelda like yeah are
you buy suits from arcane can you can't
hi that's right now there's fishing pole
though you know what I'll buy a fishing
yeah you can fish in this game yes oh
yeah we did
dude we got so much money rolling in it
I'm rolling in that you get that bait
yeah yeah yeah normal words no more
anything else maybe it's something that
comes in late cuz I'm pretty sure I
remember buying suits in the hotel
now you can buy some of the milk barn
first day of investigation it's been one
day clear we haven't had any sound
dropout yet though no we haven't watch
we're gonna find out that you're on your
switch the audio doesn't drop out it
just crackles just crackles Kurtz is the
one that drops out but doesn't crackle
I'm gonna start it up and figure out
that all my sound is just inverted or
something like we're all gonna have
different audio issues so one person I
saw in reddit was saying that it started
happening for them when they started
driving and so what about just going
down it all comes down to this please
enjoy this police car also a couple of
people in the chat were complaining
about the driving in the past versions a
pleasant surprise
you don't like driving get the radio
[Music]
because he talks over it the entire time
I have to tell you Zak this place simply
amazes me
the keys were left on the front hood and
nobody stole the car
values bunch of good people this town
house what the country let's head over
to the sheriff's department
let's do it here we go right all right
all the friends are gone
Wow yeah yeah flare do I have that like
in car view let's give it a shot
going would that frame rate confirm race
car whoa oh boy also yeah I can't hear
the car sound at all
yep there's no car sound at all there
was no car sound I'm not hearing
anything just miss your wipers work
that's good that's good that's good
my blinker yep other blinker yep yep
okay hold on I got pulled the map and
the map is funny because this is the
most you can zoom out that's as you
concerns this far is so there's there's
a button in the director's cut that lets
you bring up the map while you're
driving okay that's like see if it has
here this map is a dog yes yeah so it
packets the Dalmatian a dog yeah which
is really good but yeah the map is
literally useless okay I'm so I think
there's a way to like make that better
so I would definitely miss hold on
hitting all my buttons nope
we just get out in the middle of the
road really quick zach is there
something here that you want to check
out we're supposed to go through
anagrams file at this anagram if you
want to act on a hunch that I'm with you
ooh cars waking up all right yeah so no
car sound effects also a cool bit of
trivia luck points a spy fiction which
is yeah so yeah alarm is not working
either oh boy
as soon as that talk prompt comes up
we'll see if that I heard that doesn't
play either if that's a deal-breaker so
how does it feel yes normally he talks
during this part no I want to hear him
talk shame so this lines up with what
that person read it said which was
totally fine until they got into the car
and started
Kurt was claiming on his that it was
just doing it randomly yeah and it would
happen even outside of the car so it's
mixed bag you don't know where you're
gonna get so everyone's having a
different experience oh he's dog nose if
I want to hear him talk I know also the
framerate in this car is a little rough
which is I mean I'm used to it but I'm
surprised just because the rest of it
they would clean this up a bit this is
uh this is a bit rough for sure we still
get the fun facts but is it like veering
to the left and right a lot the car yeah
it's fine it's okay so I think the frame
rates kind of what was talking about the
car going slower than he remembers it I
think it might just be because of the
frame rate yeah the car is really slowly
slower and I think the frame rate is
just gone dying it looks like you're
driving it like 10 miles an hour is that
GPS in the middle of the car actually
like updating with what you're doing
ah that could probably the thing that's
causing an issue
no it's not good thank goodness I don't
think so that'd be ideal what there's no
reason for the head well why would they
add that that's unfortunate classic York
move I couldn't you know what I can
accept the frame rate with the car if
they at least fix the audio issue that's
that's the real deal breaker for me
really good
sigh I got I got to hear my my my
Francis York Morgan dialogue mm-hmm yeah
I want I just want to hear him talk that
was the fun part I want to read it no
sauce bites fashion everyone I'm getting
in Thomas's biscuits sing about Thomas
I love the dialogue when you first
entered changes depending on what time
you show up like this game has so much
like yeah it's it's like yeah it's all
dependent on like what time of day
you're doing things and then the
characters keep doing like going about
their schedule yes all the frames have
found the like Stone said the police
touch scenes have like different
dialogue depending on when you show up
or if you have someone with you and it's
it's like a really impressive is a
day/night cycle everything's like people
have pleasure to meet you teens that
they follow
I'm Thomas mcclain the sheriff's
assistant Thomas let me see your
biscuits
he's got biscuits in town that's his
thing please just call me it's what
everyone calls me
thank you for retrieving my belongings
from my car
Thanks no no just doing my job
I just
I want to help do everything he can to
help the investigation no Thomas Thomas
he's a good boy he's a good point she
was such a bright and lovely girl did
you know her well
well it's kind of weird I understand
just try to relax can I have a look at
this file now York City is also
certified Bangor we get to hear that
much but it's good okay start poking
around the police station yeah which
guys got going on in here hey what's up
in this kitchen mmm you can shave in
their kitchen I gotta find the dumbbell
there's a there it is uh Arnold Arnold
Arnold I haven't met anyone by that name
yet could it be the owner of this
dumbbell maybe pause you think Zach you
got dumbbell hey yeah let's put this in
my back like casually carry dumbbell I
get the grey squirrel keys start flying
squirrels by turkey sandwich the most
disgusting turkey sandwich it's like
purple it's not a sinner sandwich and
that's all about know all the center
sandwich yes
blow hello hello whoa what's in the
locker room what is this
Oh iron body long no falling squirrel
totally squirrel keys
nope nothing in their age my super funny
zoo is he feeling filthy okay he's only
had half a day
I do like how the lighting oh my god Oh
what happened
I just ate question across the a lot of
squirrel keys
that's the pointy tail flying squirrel
home I think the action one you've got
to find is damaged downstairs I think
yeah remember right ah the fire exit
observe also camera angle didn't change
there no they fix that nasty cut
yeah yeah it like the game would switch
to this life fixed camera angle just
when you go down that set of stairs the
controls wouldn't change and it would be
so hard also glad that both of us
realize that as it happened because I
felt anticipation as you came up I know
I was like I was like preparing for it
okay let's see open these things up can
we get these keys oh that sound of all
the sounds is gone gone oh no where's
the audio we have to save and restart
the game
oh it is gone gone no the Sun is
completely dropped out
oh no no so that's what Kurt had a
couple videos of his like the sound just
dropping out completely
no audio we could uh we could for
science purposes maybe close out close
the game close the game I'm gonna back
up and see if it so apparently the
resets it does come back when you
restart the game and it's the only way
to do with the curtain is found
Kurt's just the only source of
information I have on this point I mean
if we weren't doing a live stream I'd be
like oh let's try to see how long it
takes from maybe having it come back or
something right because we're on Elijah
sure might be good to just hit the save
and then restart the game we started
we're at 12 o'clock so we still have
like I have half hour yeah I don't want
to have a half hour of acting we can
sing the song yeah like yeah all play
York I'm just gonna sing the whistle in
the background and all the other
characters talk talk talk all the talks
yeah you're right it's like completely
gone Wow all right let's save okay yeah
it's really weird the sound this dropped
out there's that raincoat boy I do like
the the logo or the I like that yeah the
avatar is not bad it could be other
things but I'm into it think I need the
logo in there oh yeah the thing for me
I'm red that was work just staring I
want I want the the the smile that he
makes after he gets his Deadly
Premonition from his coffee cup just
that I just want that
I don't people still care but I know
that was a big thing people would like
very much care about their switch icon
I'd be like it needs to be like there'd
be like patch updates where they just
fixed the icon because people would
complain about it the first one was like
sneak pass or something that really
needed it okay we've got music okay we
got this let's see if this fixes it
we're doing some live bug testing for ya
oh you do get caught up every time you
you load back into the I remember this
game and Alan Wake came out like within
two weeks of each other really Alan Wake
also is heavily based on twin peaks and
also has a previously on like I remember
this is so weird
Alex also a very good game yeah highly
recommend audios back yeah that's good
they both have like their own version of
the log lady from like twin peaks' I
like this game has the pot lady and then
Alan Wake has a lamp lady it's real
weird that is weird
I found many keys which he tried listen
I know that he like explains to you like
the history of each I think squirrel is
that your punishment is having a man
squirrels so love the like holding it up
ah I've got it
like I'm no York it's a real caloric
amorous situation he's just explain to
me why do you have someone flying
squirrel he's we needed this music I
love games teach you weird facts like
this like I'm gonna like persona has to
like explain you like different types of
coffee and Katherine explains about like
beer and alcohol this game teaches you
about flying squirrels just keep going
how long did it get rid of the other one
I think I'll try this one
okay you
the key I hope so did it yeah yeah yes
York this this is a flying squirrel it
was a bathtub you messed up again
sugar I can man this really is a twin
peaks' and he's so patient - he just
keeps going through this over and over
all right well next one let's keep going
actually I think it's the one that has
the outline I think it is - at this
point I kind of just was getting all the
facts all the squirrel facts are
happening oh York
this isn't me - look at the size of
those record books behind him there's a
huge ronke a Siberian chipmunk
quite a popular pet alright I'll do the
proper one let's do it I think we've
only got one other key though yeah this
is a great doing Louis I feel like this
is uh like the proper way that this
scene probably went down like I'm sure
this is like a canon situation I know
this is a grey squirrel
sorry grey squirrel nothing particularly
special about the grey squirrel I'm
afraid oh wow great grey school doesn't
even get any fun facts he sounds like
annoyed but also genuine at the same
time this book is great
alright give us a shot of me it you
found the key
that's the one uh-huh he's excited yes
a southern flying squirrel thank you so
much go fast go fast yeah I could tell
me about the southern flying squirrel oh
well Zach we just got here and we've
cracked a big case already
[Laughter]
[Music]
the victimless crime yes music solve out
saw was to me this is like the the bass
music occasion you're driving around to
it yes she lived with her mother Sally
on his father died in an accident in the
lumber mill when she was a child
Thomas is biscuit her mother is
unemployed and lives on the insurance
money from her husband's accident
the white poster is for other people
connections serial murderers could be
part of it
my name is great season 2 is excellent I
should watch it yeah really
everyone's talking so much praise about
it hey city folk huh no no I take that
back
all of them can't be as bad as him and
some should have better manners no
talking smack this is a good biscuit
never tasted a biscuit is delicious
we're in town can I get these actually
[Music]
Thomas you're a terrible cop what an
excellent Baker
oh my agent Morgan the autopsies ready
you are welcome to accompany me to the
Greenville General Hospital Emily you
come to Thomas Thomas to here make more
biscuits use the car outside let's get
going you might think this is just a
small-town police investigation but our
inspections are thorough and solid I'm
hoping you won't slow us down
it's a good biscuit look George I get
that we're gonna go in to understand
that I need to enjoy this biscuit
this biscuit alright let's get to the
hospital
yeah me uh uh sure Johnson oh the town
hall scene is really good when you
finally like meet everybody and you get
you get a chance to like meet all the
weird characters hospitals gonna check
out though these hospitals good yeah I'm
just thinking about good this game is
fun
Oh
and I think all the logos on the items
are the whole ones to change I think
those are the new ones oh yeah I
remember I remember the background
stocking with a detailed in the original
it was more plain very well which is
like final fantasy arm gesture your
involvement in this case is limited ah
always laying down the law you don't
have to learn your way around - wow
that's the one George the hospital
closes at 21 it's 10:00 it seems like
you have plenty of time
hey we need a hurry twelve hours into
the hospital and maybe it takes really
long to get there possibly long drive
right when you're going ten miles an
hour I can only get us there as fast as
this car is gonna go to the town yeah he
does not like him he does not like him
either
let's go yeah sounds good sure who's
good here we go and now it's raining
no discuss why are we driving why aren't
why isn't one of them driving it's eight
York was like I need to get a custom of
the town okay it's ready to drive but
like he knows how to get to the house
and he's like get us there as quickly as
possible ten hours before this place
closes no one else's okay
I hope I'm gone talking yeah so this is
happening okay although we're still not
getting the car sounds unfortunately in
fashion ships and I are leaving
strangers I don't know which way to go
back home that way no okay no no that
would go back that road and then off to
the left so you need to turn around okay
so if I turn around go there
there
we've got this yeah this is the
conversation though because we've always
a thing did I mess that up member it'll
pop up again oh I think you're right I
think it like resets will they have the
same conversation good the good thing
suppose the car conversations are very
we should definitely yes because you
could like decide not to go with them
and they'll go off on their own but then
you'll miss like all these really nice
conversations so hmm
what a place for a fence come on car
[Laughter]
question is a chat is sweary making the
sequel yes he is directing and writing
and directing and writing the story will
be no no I'll be I'll be exactly what we
need
feeling it oh now the framerate is
picking up a little bit which is weird
because it's raining yeah that is very I
think it's because we got away from the
like all the buildings this looks a
little bit better than earlier and then
all ability no one's talking anymore and
it's awkward all the frames are gone
yeah the frames are
okay he cuts a lot yeah my cutting to a
left here yeah I'm pretty sure one more
[Music]
the animation of the menu closing into
the 12 frames driving
let's see if we can get to the hospital
by the end of the street we've got 15
spells yeah this our there's one
building in particular that's really I
think it's the art galleries like little
squirrely yeah I guess I missed that
dialog shoot okay well hot tip and when
you play this don't pause in the middle
of conversations you'll miss him the
frame rates gotten very fast all of a
sudden yeah which makes this he mess
kind of hard to control
I don't think it's locked or anything
yeah well we made it to the hospital
cop rains just coming down pouring and
that's all procedurally like I think
there's a couple of specific scenes
where it happens but for the most part
the weather system time yeah dynamic
weather I know that affects like
people's routines change depending on
the weather and they like at different
time of day yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
whoo yeah that PS definitely having
audio issues
impressive
oh yeah that probably needs to give I
hope it gets I do too
let me stop the car stuff I can live
with audio should be need to be
something with headphones on oh and not
a fun time
[Music]
he's talking like a rink it's like a
poncho they're just standing out in the
rain I guess they're used to it if you
like that's enough the hood on or
anybody's just can't pick testicles v
pickles all right Hospital time Fiona
hello frankly Fiona
hi there Fiona we're here to see mush
Johnson is in the computer computer in a
hospital doctors Rica's playing there
[Music]
Luther land parties anyway that butchers
pops up out of nowhere it's a recent
best-selling mystery it's set in the
u.s. a small traditional North American
town close to the Canadian border home a
peaceful traditional place however that
peaceful town is shattered by terrible
emergence adness to everyone in town
that everyone is a seditious meanest
evil still lurking alive yes much like
the situation right
whether she said it see that sorry I
shouldn't have said that on a dead and
all the work books are written to
entertain you it's good you're enjoying
the girls live here is a terrible party
much different from that of a novel
which oh there's no need to apologize
Thank You agent York that's a nice
little Hospital yeah yeah I've got some
real-time reflections dynamic weather
still great racing where's dr. Johnson
oh I love the little uh do not enter but
[Laughter]
it's on every door you can't go into it
just he's he's all all the way
downstairs isn't he
sounds right yeah I'm only slightly
recalling this because we played it on
extra life like two years ago and I
remember specifically getting to this
part because it was kind of late the day
was like almost passing out and I was
playing I need to find my way through
this hospital I feel like a zoom out
okay
you can't zoom out on a piece of paper
that's the thing I could just follow the
arrow yeah probably should be placer
both Yakuza and Deadly Premonition have
very prominent four-step zones it's not
a coincidence you think mm-hmm no no no
a little bit louder than the most most
other things in the game we couldn't not
the computer room Fiona needs to check
her information what do you mean
[Laughter]
and meats I don't remember those posters
looking takes that Jesus criminy yeah
the original those might be from the
director's cut it's a simple puzzle
exactly it's taken on its challenge
puzzle time to solve a puzzle can Casas
Brooke
oh yeah if I remember you literally just
need to like click on the things right
there's order so that's King King King
first King Brooke Rucker no that one
rook yeah I'm sorry it's been forever
since I played Bishop Bishop is that one
night is that one there you go
that was easy oh man I bet doesn't a
periodic periodic symbol on the menu
another code but there's no way to
insert a password it's periodic
for gains Oh fancy gesture no need
George he's real fed up with this it
appeared with the card key it's telling
us where to use it Pam this is not the
time to be joking around agent Morgan
just solved the first puzzle for you
jo-jo she is below with the deceased
with honor below being underground I
take it simple I'll get there using this
key card to meet the mischievous
architect of this
[Applause]
[Music]
- its it's the solving crimes song you
just gotta ride it out and then it's
gone
check another $10 you're checking the
weather thank you you just get money for
doing things I love it
BAM you'll find that door to go
downstairs now
nope all right my fault but this is down
the door I can't believe it Sears were
just around the corner though so that's
good
oh what's this Mike yeah yeah there you
go done oh oh hello camera you've left
the camera behind there for a second
swipe that card open that door space
sounds
I remember this just being a hassle to
get through yeah it was it's kind of
tedious you just running around for a
while good things save because you get
done talking to him yes it was also so
much money it does yeah that's when it
gets real exciting hmm this is the door
I found it cool I think we do have just
enough time to go through this scene
yeah yeah before we call it oh sure
sorry to keep you waiting
this is Nate that's and then there's
like a character who just looks like
Wesley Snipes I think like he's like the
gunsmith and his name's like Wesley like
I'm just like you're really just Morgan
let's call me York please call me York
everybody call everyone calls me do you
do very well
agent York are you a forensic
practitioner let's just say I've dealt
with corpses before you just said yes by
the way did you create that yourself
mm-hmm I just want to destroy what is
this that's it George
but I'm glad you liked it
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's like a let's get back to the
situation here doubt obstructing an
investigation you've angered the monarch
from the onset of rigor mortis
stiffening of the muscles but Timon do
you think they got the same composer for
too windy and 2100 hours
I really hope something that's at least
as good as life is beautiful it's gotta
have some bangers in there yeah pressure
box around the neck and a long cut
running from chest abdomen
blood marks on her right hand tell us
she was gripping something round here
right hand just like my hands I have
hands soon
I've often gripped things with them I
know what that's like it probably
happened to her after she was killed
someone go back and talk about the fact
that her name is anagram now I first
thought not only that if every character
in the game like corresponds with one
letter in the alphabet
and you don't realize it until the end
where they like show like the actors in
the credits and they like specifically
like point out that like yep this
there's 26 characters in this game one
for every letter the alphabet which
means she was cut up while she was still
alive
no good that's not yes a shop knife was
used it was inserted beneath the sternum
and then quickly sliced downwards the
excessive loss of blood from her
internal organs is what actually killed
her her nails are clean and with no skin
cells from the attacker she also doesn't
appear to have been bound nor badly
beaten she was apparently killed without
resistance
the most tragic thing however was that
she was unable to speak her story to
anyone who could hear a cries
- when we learn about the red seeds yes
the perpetrator cutout and his tongue I
believe she was drugged first to face
her consciousness and then the killer
killed her the killer most likely has a
deep traumatized past concerning women
Bob I've been watching a lot of mine
hundred just like yes yeah we're we're
breaking us down suggest a very lonely
either that or a food hardcore sales
we must get on like how we're like until
he listens yeah yeah I'm just like yeah
okay awesome
if people haven't played this game they
probably want to hear rise for dialogue
case in Seattle in 1985 report to your
fine for any more blatant we're gonna
get sued you can't keep making these
[Laughter]
fully deeply painfully aware of what was
happening to her boy tell me what time
did it stop raining on the night Anna
was killed uh just before I went to bed
right after the movie on TV ended so
around 1:00 a.m. what movie was it did
by John Landis 1981 anyway it stopped
accompanied by the ending song blue moon
George would you mind if I examined Anna
myself what more do you hope to find I'm
sure I mentioned that I have a personal
interest in cases like these hello hi
there boy just gonna do that whole bunch
yep
I'll have sound
and it's got the thing on it his holding
there we go there we go whoo from our
lack of resistance I'd say that Anna's
injuries happened very quickly unable to
speak she was then left to cry herself
to death we're gonna end this dream on a
real like intense no yeah
the perpetrator stayed with her for at
least two hours until it stopped raining
had to have had a really good time of
her death it was still raining I call
them the raincoat killer tear marks on
her cheeks that means she was killed
under a roof somewhere hmm she was then
carried into the woods after it stopped
raining hmm there's one other thing her
tongue was removed with a very
comfortable simply chopped off
Osia are you pass scuse me pardon me
what a strange thing to ask have you
heard my music the women love me
George the perpetrator is just like you
he's passionate about women
he's a passionate kisser this wasn't
Joseph's death the perpetrator bit off
ya know we'll never get a dental print
from a wound like this but this is still
a big lead
[Music]
[Music]
they're good they're emphasized for
effect
yeah it happens it you feel it Zack
Jack on our old time all-american
sightseeing tour just came to an end
this case is now under the jurisdiction
of the FBI I'm assuming command I'll
need you to assist me in the
investigating just like Jordans like
excuse me what if it flips it on I found
this as much as every other passionate
man on earth let me show you something
sometimes Japanese really deserve like
better names for games so the Japanese
title for this game is red seed profile
which yeah also fits it pretty well like
ranked rainy isn't there like rainy
summer rainy see profile yeah but the
permission is pretty good too
the original box ours like so generic
it's like so they've got the name in
that box it's like something you'd find
out like some top secret the back of
like a block yester next like species
George Emily we should be going no need
to stay here any longer okay okay I have
to sign the release just give me a
moment very well made really suck if you
don't walk through that door and
everything is kind of went to hell I
sure hope nothing spooky his rook takes
your queen and your Knight takes rook
and checkmate huh
what's with that guy oh my god my theory
[Music]
my first victory in the grandmaster
ranking there's no reason to do that see
now it's 15 plus 1 bullets oh yeah 15 in
the clip and 1 in the hole hey York
something's wrong with the hospital well
it's already nice man how'd it get so
gross in here there are vines everywhere
I swear it wasn't like this they never
make it a hundred percent clear if it's
like all in is left up to interpretation
for sure yeah all right well that is
actually the perfect place yeah
stop this is where we left off during
the well well thank you guys for joining
us but yeah this has been Deadly
Premonition origins which you can play
on the Nintendo switch right now do ya
you can get it for $30 it's available
it's got some audio issues so but we
tested it and so if you have some audio
issues just restart the game just sayin
and then open the game back up hopefully
they'll get a patch for that cuz this
looks like it might be one of the better
places to actually play it mm-hmm some
weird performance issues when you go
into towns but that's yeah but the game
is so good a lot of peaking audio game
is fun and if you've never played it or
if you want to revisit it this is a good
opportunity to do that and then
definitely Deadly Premonition
to sometime 2020 you're gonna stay
aboard
you're gonna skateboard all right thanks
guys for watching we'll see you next
time
[Music]
you